[موسيقى]
اسره
لايدي ارنوب يمشي في الغابه ياكل جزرا
بغرابه والاسد قد سمع
نداءه لما نادى اصحابه ارنوب يمشي في
الغابه ياكل جزرا غرابه والاسد قد سمع
نداءه لما نادى اصحابه ارنب في الغابه
يمشي والاسد يراه صيدا شهي ارنب في الغابه
يمشي والاسد يراه صيدا شهي اهلا يا صديقي
ارنوب اسمع مني ما اطلب ماذا لو نلعب غ
ميضه ول تبدا قبلي بالعد لا فلتبدا انت
العد ولن تمسكني هذا محال ودعني اختبئ
سريعا اغمض عينيك في الحال ارنب في الغابه
يمشي والاسد يراه صيدا شهي ارنب في الغابه
يمشي والاسد يراه دا شهيد نظر يمينا
ويسارا لاثار خطاه يتابع واصل بحثه
فتفاجئ انقذه سريعا احسن ارنوب
صنيعا قال له شكرا ارنوب اصبحت عندي محبوب
ارنوب في الغ
يمشي والاسد يراه صديقا وفي ارنب في
الغابه يمشي والاسد يراه صديقا
[موسيقى]
وفي